all right you know what industry is
still booming during the pandemic design
and construction and the national
kitchen and bath association has
launched a program
to recruit and empower our youth that
are ready to build i spoke to the
company ceo to learn more
so we're talking about the nkba and you
guys are launching a new program but
first
introduce us to the company yeah so
we're the national kitchen and bath
association
we're a trade association that
represents really all aspects
of the trades that produce a kitchen and
our bath
and we have a large trade show that we
at times host in las vegas called the
kitchen bath industry show
and we partner with the national
association of home builders to create
designing construction week
we have education certification programs
for the design community and
other trade professionals as well and we
launched this new program
really um after a lot of our members had
been talking about
the shortage in labor and and how
difficult it was to find certain skill
sets and also the right
the rising wage rate for certain
positions was driven really by the
shortage
and can we hear more about this next
step program that sounds really good for
the community
yeah so we know that through 2028
there's over 700 000 jobs that are
expected to open up in the design and
construction industry
and we want to do our part to really
make sure the conversation is had with
young people
as they consider careers we just want to
make sure that young people understand
um how lucrative it is to work in the
skilled trades and really the trades in
general
um so we're trying to do our part by
launching this next step initiative
and i hear you're also partnering up
with bridgier let's talk more about that
yeah so we were seeking a partner um you
know knowing we needed an expert in this
field
really looking at how do you reach the
young people and we found this
organization and it's based in houston
texas it just has a wonderful
group that is focused on really helping
educate young people and how you
really bring um young people into the
fold as far as what you want to explain
to them and
i looked at it like this if you go to a
job fair you know years and years ago
you walk around at a bunch of tables
with papers on them and you talk to
people
and you know it's very hard for young
person to understand
with the plethora of data and
information that you know they all have
access to and the technology they have
access to you really need to kind of
you know penetrate you with your story
and we felt that bridgier really could
bring
um a good understanding of a hands-on
experience
uh to the gymnasiums of of high schools
and show young people
really act out a part of what is it like
to be a plumber what's it like to work
uh as a designer in a showroom can you
give us some examples of what you've
heard from people that have participated
in these class tours
we had one young young man who um part
of the electrical
program was that they had to make a
light bulb light up and it walked them
through the process and literally you
would have thought they invented
something
when they saw this light bulb but it was
so touching to see somebody
and he actually said and you know we're
you know you appreciate this from the
production side of what you do
we're videoing this and he said i'm
gonna be an electrician and this isn't a
five-year-old kid
this is a high school kid who who really
was touched by
like wow look what i just did and i can
do this
so awesome for more details on the
national kitchen and bath association
just visit
nkba.org and there is more on las vegas
now coming up
in